HISCHIER PLAYS ONE IN.
THAT IS FOUGHT OFF.
IT IS OFF THE OUTSIDE OF THE  WS
FACE OFF ONE BIOTEAU  BY OFF HE.
BOUNCING PUCK, TAKEN OF THE HUR
NUMBER 1 NHL
GAME.
THREE 'CANES DEEP IN THEENTER.
SHOTS ARE 5-3, CAROLINA.
THE DEVILS WITH THREE EARLIER,
I'M STILLHERE, NO SHOTS
YET FOR IT.
THAT'S THE DIFFERENCE.
IF HE COULD HAVE GOTTEN LINING
AGAINST HIM.
BUT JUS POINT.
WITH A PASS DOWN LOW.
DOLLAR REPLAY BROUGHT TO YOU BY
MERCER ON THE PUCK.
SEVERSON, INTO THE HIGH SHOT.
BOQVIS OF THE ONLY TIMES
WE'VE SEEN IN THE TWO DEVILS'
POWER PLAYS WHEHE AGAIN.
SLAVIN, BANKS A HUGE GLOVE 1-0 O
THE THIRD PERIOD OVER CAROLINA.
>> Ken: GREAT POINT BY YOU, MAN
GOOD TO FIND THE OPEN LANE.
HERE IS ZETTERLUND'S OPPORTUNIT.
HE WAS A 14-GOAL SCORER DOWN
THERE FOR THE A
AN OUTNUMBERED SITUATION UNTIL
ANCE TO WIN THE DIVISION IF
THEY HOLD JUST INSIDE THE
CANE BLUE LINE.
DRAGS THAT PUCK.PS, ANTICIPATIO
GOOD THE PLAYOFFS WILL BE PIECE.
THERE'S THAT PASS RIGHT UP THE
MIDDLE.
HE USED THAT SPEED TO GETN THE .
AGAIN, WE KNOW HOW DIF
HAMILTON IS IN.
SKJEI ON THE PUCK.
I THOUGHT SAW
SO INOB.
HE ACTUALLY TIPS THAT PUCK DOWN
TO HIMSELF AND USES THAT BIG
BODY IN FRONT.
SEVERSON WILL BANK IT CAROLINA.S